[Music]
welcome to Palm City fresh world new
customizations and the return of cops
make Palm City and urban oasis for those
who burn fast and live by their own the
daytime off with sanctioned racing
events through the Speed Hunter show
they compete and score Bank with each
you win then use the rewards to tweak
your car's performance and visual
customization cops patrol the streets
during the day but they play by the
rules
finding you for speeding and limiting
your progress using control moves to
slow you down roam the open-world nab
challenges and collectibles as much time
here as you like when you ready switch
into night
build your rep i competing in illicit
street races the more you win the more
your heat will rise in the more rep
you'll gain but up and all eyes on you
comes with the price tops are on another
level at night and you'll become a
target as your heat level increases as
it gets higher they'll ratchet up their
efforts to stop you leasing helicopters
and ridings to take you down the
coordinated efforts that adapt to the
situation push it too far and they won't
hold back and your car can only take so
much damage so be sure to make it to a
hideout or the garage without getting
busted otherwise you'll lose everything
you've risked step into your garage
where you can tune your setup to your
like pick a car and make it your own
we've replaced the speed cards from
payback you can now unlock parts by
building up rep at night use the bank
you've earned during the day to level up
your ride almost every car can be
transformed into a custom win the revamp
material editor adds a dynamic range of
style combinations while the new exhaust
tuning system did you ride a mark to go
with this bike
man go beyond the car craft and create
your own unique avatar to represent your
style Palm City
the first time ever a need for speed you
can now customize your favorite rides
going out download need for speed heat
studio today for an early access into
car customization with weekly car drops
a full line of custom parts and a rap
editor you can now build your custom
ride and connect your account to push it
directly into the game get the app show
off your need for speed style today all
Drive will be available in lunch crew up
with your friends or let us pair you up
with others so you never ride alone you
Cruise rides will be displayed in you
garage you're always up to speed with
the latest creations leaderboards and
challenges are tightly connected to the
crew so push each other to be the best
and get a one-up on the wall every days
danger every race means risk now the
chance to lose everything you've worked
for or
being something more
[Music]
turn the key burn all limits
[Music]